this is what I love about HR you learn
these little intricacies about people
Margaret's gonna show us some meaning of
trust I mean what am I really doing this
summer I mean I sent the kids away to
camp I'm redesigning bathrooms sink
Brooklyn exposed brick and a urinal meg
wants me standing up again yeah few
neighbors aren't wasting any time of it
are they hey yo spying on the neighbors
all right we're the Joneses such a
lovely Street the Chinese don't even
have a word first we like this and they
would say a [ __ ] hood Englander quite
as a default coming out of your mouth
you don't think there's something off
about them both so overly accomplished
and stylish welcome to the Cobra Club of
differently expected that looks like a
real snake snake why that's real Cobra
do you have tab I'm following Natalie
Jones
Oh Karen Natalie I was just leaving tema
voicemail he likes to hear from me when
I'm trying on lingerie it's one of our
things Dan Jeff have a think we do it
really fast in case the kids come
running into our room all right these
people we need evidence I just want to
make sure this is not paranoia
there's a missile mama wants to cuddle
here's the thing about trust once it's
gone bad things can happen get the card
now I count the three okay fine oh my
god you can't be serious fitted with a
miniature surveillance mic it's
completely undetectable
we don't get out very often so we really
like to make the most of it